[Music]
Kakuta is a tiny islet in the Zanzibar
archipelago off the coast of Tanzania in
East Africa
[Applause]
for centuries Cotton's have prospered
for making a living off the land and
safe it is not the kind of place you'd
expect to find people innovatively
adapting to climate change but that's
exactly what they're doing
[Music]
life here hinges on solving huge
problems things like deforestation water
shortages and a collapsing fishery
climate change is making all of their
problems even worse and the Cotten's
survival depends upon their ability to
adapt
[Music]
Hyuna Hyuna Buddhist amar Kumar the
Seminole America muhabba nephewcompoop
Allen Gianni pilot bassy ha ha ha ha ha
Munna between G sana
alia Vanessa Centofanti Laguna Salada
wonderful coupons imipenem economy -
Papa Harry unequivocally mahaparinirvana
katakana meanwhile a mangaka national a
kook
[Music]
we can start to get a feeling of how
disastrous global deforestation would be
by looking at Kakuta without a tree
canopy ground temperatures skyrocketed
soils couldn't retain moisture and
without the grip of a dense network of
tree roots they quickly turned into dust
Baruch Musa
Omar is from the neighbouring island of
Pemba when he visited Kuwata for the
first time the islet was teetering
towards collapse Moran was only Dakota
[Music]
from Valley chokobo autonomous skinny
sana
hakuna Julian
hoppin a dispenser how Kuno Mimi
hakuna Maggie retractor nice idea La
Quinta finale I'm a skinny segue no way
so what about guess if Lana now and I
was a new class idea what taco Kota
Baruch realized that his Island Pemba
was headed in the exact same direction
as piccata Kazakh llaman anodd Oh yawns
Oh binky the Amagi veña veña Patera
lucky the 7-meter you're to the pit of
my depending equally v-i window sunny
but so come on I won over by a clever
committee in a mannequin I've been doing
by aki ali mahalia now meaty enough when
teleport a baroque thought that if he
could figure out how to get trees in the
ground in Pemba that he might be able to
do the same for Co kata Baruch also knew
he couldn't tackle island-wide refer a
station alone so he recruited Jeff
Schnurr a 21 year old Canadian tree
planter I came to pemba seven years ago
now and I was just living here I was
trying to write a novel at the time I
didn't really know what I wanted to do
with my life and borrow kind of heard
that I was a tree planter came and we
spent several long evenings just
discussing you know what tree planting
could look like you're in Pemba it was
all fairly amateur we didn't have a lot
of the expertise but we had a lot of
Drive and motivation and that first year
we were able to grow a hundred thousand
seedlings
[Music]
it was an operation run on a smile and a
handshake and we started getting support
the Finnish Embassy supported us and
then the European Union did and that
really helped us take it to the next
level Baruch and Jeff with a perfect
team
while Jeff concentrated an international
fundraising efforts
Baruch could focus on managing things on
the ground
he immediately headed back to Kolkata
began about a hydrolysis to a
sequestered yalla malsu demo him oh wow
a custom awareness it has a little a
master heated ECC the Maggie a shulam
but another final work of several
America tonight you foot beam a genie
combi yo to miracles masala petechiae
like any society casual in English on a
new combat anatomy Ahmadi truth come a
Porsche boom bow at magic you know Tony
when you are taught wanna children of
the village and when all the cabeza we'd
sing in a tangled a in the condo to
make us eat American scum Billy
but I know in a quest 11100 to bacilli
possible nutrition in la piscina Melissa
[Music]
now Hatake team but when they are the
kakuta Vasaloppet a saltwater
Machiavelli newcomer what avocado and a
surfer the idea of muscle community
[Music]
Wow y jis'w deserves a command email
even in the independent cosmos
buddy what you know now I was easy
Nico - Karina rainwater harvesting
vanadium idea for - de pata YPG
challenge which aku phenomena for new
umbrellas on Avenida bandit of the band
Aviv and of abandonment viene de
Bougainville Borges idea was to build
Cuates a very first school and used the
roof to collect rainwater Coco Jones
worked round the clock for months to
complete the water tank and the school
and in March 2012 Coco Jones were
finally able to turn on a tap on a dream
yes Emperor Otto how come in magazine II
had received media VP like jicama keep
Tom but you'll come on daughter the
romantic activity
una um publication transition Asarco
cotton or vegetative not a soccer ball
Nalu kudiye miss whelan imagine to help
Cotton's conserve their precious water a
group of women in Pemba volunteered to
grow thousands of seedlings in their own
nursery to establish a new forest in
Kolkata
[Music]
noxeema
any of our limiting go quadrille here
yogi father miss it
Nicaragua a semi are whiny Ocasio Jack
of water as a Cosima hardly happy to
live Monica Rivonia committed
now he's in a gulag Oh potato hockey
Pampanga leo about a cro-magnon or Azusa
[Music]
it was economic development on one side
communities were planting trees for
fruit timber to make a living but the
end result was an area that was now
covered in trees yes you could harvest
some trees and you still had a forest
conservation was a day job our model is
that economic development is directly
opposed to environmental conservation we
can't conserve the natural world because
we need jobs we yes we need to fight
climate change but look at the cost we
can't afford to do that we're in a
recession that's a completely ludicrous
way of thinking impendence showed us
that economic development and
environmental conservation are not
opposed they're actually intertwined
in addition to the reforestation efforts
Co curtains have completely revamped
their approach to farming and are now
using renewable energy to charge
portable household batteries proving
that adapting to climate change doesn't
have to lead to a less comfortable
lifestyle
[Music]
Sawadee way to take it easy NACO cotton
are safe when you have an attacker when
delhi - indira Rama Hari nahi vomica
camp on Cabeza de Vaca watch botulinum
Artemisia mokuba
Yahoo knee when attorney open for the
magico viola to me upon American Amelia
Bedelia KU pikir
where Honam phenom dualism nephrons or
equivocation Baggio pahala Parvati katha
kaadu near Basilan Wow come over
tomorrow
when you look at the whole planet you
can get overwhelmed and you you realize
looking at koko de that that's the
planet we're good at taking mother
nature and using it to to support us
we're good at growing but there's a
limit it's not even about sacrifice it's
about changing and shifting our way of
thinking pick the smallest problem you
could solve we didn't plant 1.3 million
trees overnight it was one seed at a
time at first one community at a time it
was actually a small problem because it
wasn't on the pendent scale or at the
global scale it was it was just a couple
of people with an idea and I hope that
they could actually do it
[Music]
all my dreams are coming true heavy
shackles used to hold me down now my
feet don't we reaching the ground just
like a prisoner when is sandins and all
my dreams are coming true all my dreams
are coming true
[Music]
you